oh my god it is so great to meet you I'm
such a huge fan you're so talented I
made a joke but give like you don't want
to give jobs away but you're so talented
thank you that's 17 years in the making
due to me y'all are friends in real life
when did y'all meet we actually met in
acting class every time we met when we
hit first both moved to New York from
New York to LA yeah I'd never had a day
job before cuz I just gotten out of
college and had no idea how to do
anything no practical life skills
whatsoever
one of the things I didn't know how to
do is how to hold a tray and I really
needed a job at a restaurant and had a
very important interview coming up at
the Bubba Gump shrimp company at
Universal CityWalk definitely yes I knew
how to hold the dress so I was like you
know Bubba Gump shrimp coming he's gonna
want you to hold the tray the end so I
actually brought kid into the restaurant
I was working at and you know showed him
a thing or two I don't think I told you
about mistress day mr. stay was that oh
we were just talking about that mistress
is when people have dates on February
13th with people they're not supposed to
even they pay with cash and they yeah
yeah they're not taking them to
bubblegum yeah that's a second mistress
then you're not the main mistress of
your eggs I've got a property on the 15
[Laughter]
did you do the Hollywood scene together
like do y'all hang out together like you
avoided the Hollywood scene together I
would say pretty well yeah we both came
from New York we're very serious stage
actors yes very not interested in any
sort of like Hollywood nonsense but we
did do our first red carpet together
okay this is East Sider season 1 when we
had just moved from YouTube cuz we've
had this crazy journey where we've gone
from YouTube to logo to Netflix now
subtitled in over 30 languages worldwide
[Applause]
when we had first moved to logo we did
our very first red carpet together but
they did not have any seats for us at
the awards show so they just let us do
the red carpet and we took a photo with
Abby Lee Miller from Dance Moms
from YouTube where do we leave you know
it makes you funny and it like all those
situations happen to all of us and
different before I got locked out of the
American Idol tour because they didn't
give me a pass what am I supposed to say
I'm coming I got a caring headshot with
you at all times I just waited out there
til somebody came to get me because I
don't want to sound like a tool let me
like I'm sorry I was like I didn't want
to be that person but for all the people
that don't know about East Siders like
what's the show about so East Siders is
a dark comedy about a gay couple in
Silver Lake and their friends and the
sad and funny messes that they make out
of their lives we've been doing it for
seven years now and we have four seasons
on Netflix the final season just
premiered and it's all about a drag
queens wedding yes
I mean is it great I'm very good
actually but is it it's the final season
so will it be hard to say goodbye since
obviously you get to work with the one
you love and it is bittersweet for sure
but I'm so proud of our little show that
we made with our friends literally in
our living room and I'm mostly so proud
of him he's the force of nature and
nobody else could have pulled this off
yeah doing all the jobs yeah all the
jobs yeah he originally wrote this
script I remember cuz we are in our
friend Boreas little apartment and he
was like I just wrote this for me not to
like make money or become famous because
this is a story that I would want to see
so can we just read this together and I
want to make this as a birthday present
to myself
and what I really loved about that is
that I think it really makes things out
of passion we're so often you see in
Hollywood people making things because
they want to sell it and it's like all
about the business and I think it just
goes to show that business follows
passion and heart and that's why it gets
been
[Applause]
you grew up in the deep south I grew up
in the dirty dirty and then there's the
dirty dirty where I'm from in
Mississippi yes I love it so but I grew
up in the south as well how hard was
that growing up in that kind of
environment being gay like really hard
wait I had to wait honestly you know I
grew up in a conservative Christian just
like ultra ultra red part of the state
and it was really hard for me to kind of
like come to grips with that but I was
blessed with a really loving family and
it wasn't easy for them at first but we
all navigated it together and came out a
stronger family on the other side of it
[Applause]
friends that I always like asking people
in the limelight about that because a
lot of people don't have the confidence
to do that and so that's why I always
ask people I like how did you do it or
when did you do what we're seeing like a
new South emerge and I think I credit
people like you honestly I've always
appreciated your support of the LGBTQ
community
I loved your tie it up music video where
you have gay couples getting married
alongside straight couples in this video
I just find that love is love is love
right love is hard enough like to find
so when you find it who the hell cares
what it looks like if you're the same or
different I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this